the russian invasion of ukraine has led
to a radical departure in german foreign
and security policy chancellor schultz
has pledged to increase defense spending
and he's also ditched a gas pipeline
project with russia a project that
former chancellor merkel refused to
touch these changes have been welcomed
by washington where just several weeks
ago lawmakers were openly
questioning germany as a reliable
partner
today germany's new defense minister
christine lambrecht visited the pentagon
in washington here's u.s defense
secretary lloyd austin speaking earlier
today
now germany has shown tremendous
leadership at this crucial moment
your chancellor's decisions to bolster
germany's armed forces are bold and
historic
and we look forward to working with you
to implement these important changes
we also salute germany's decision to
send security assistance to ukraine
your example helped to inspire other
allies and partners to follow
well my next guest tonight is matthew
karknichnik he is the chief europe
correspondent for politico here in
berlin matthew it's good to have you on
the program you wrote
i dare say a blistering piece about
german politicians in russia this week
but the headline putin's useful german
idiots and you write it shouldn't
surprise anyone that berlin spent the
past 16 years with its feet firmly
planted on the wrong side of the divide
over how to handle russia
explain to our viewers what you mean
there
well i mean that it's been clear to many
people in europe and in the united
states for quite a long time that putin
shouldn't be trusted
but germany ignored all of these
warnings uh consistently and decided
instead to do what german industry
wanted and what made sense for them from
a
energy point of view in terms of
getting cheap gas from russia to heat
german households and more importantly
even for
german industry and it ignored all of
these warnings and it worked well in the
short term
but it was a very
uh sort of myopic view i think in terms
of what russia was was really up to
you go down the list of political
parties and politicians in your article
you also call out
angela merkel for being the leader of
this disastrous policy i mean she was
often called the putin whisperer she was
considered by some even former u.s
president barack obama to be like an
oracle with a window into the kremlin
but you say that she has earned a place
in the pantheon of political naivete
alongside neville chamberlain
was angela merkel the putin whisperer
really the putin appeaser
she was definitely the the putin
appeaser she might have been whispering
to him but he certainly wasn't uh wasn't
listening and i think a lot of us looked
at her record even before this on
foreign policy and said that you know
it's not everything that a lot of people
in western capitals think it was uh not
just in terms of russia but in terms of
her policies towards towards europe uh
the greek crisis and and other issues so
uh you know i think it's sort of
interesting that you're seeing
the miracle legacy crumble
so so quickly but there can be no doubt
that this was a historic error that she
made and it goes back to the decision in
2008 in bucharest at the nato summit
when germany resisted including ukraine
and georgia in nato
and at the time the united states under
george w bush was pushing her in the
other direction she stood her ground
and eventually got the french to go
along with her and this was the
beginning of a process that has
continued up until a couple of weeks ago
of basically forgiving the russians for
every misdeed looking the other way and
continuing to pursue these gas deals and
the problem i think in a lot of people's
perception is because of the role
gerhard schroeder her predecessor as
chancellor played in all of this there's
been a lot of focus on his role and he
of course
joined as chairman of north stream two
uh the the pipeline project that has
been so controversial between russia and
germany but uh really the power rested
with merkel and the people people around
her including frankfurt steinmeier who
at the time was foreign minister from
her coalition partner the social
democrats and is now of course german
president
you highlight um in your article what is
an almost
self-righteous holier-than-thou attitude
by the political elite here in berlin
when you describe what the german
parliament did the day that ukrainian
president zielinski spoke
i mean he delivered a scathing
indictment of german complicity in the
creation of the putin war machine
what happened
directly after that speech in the
bundestag
well directly afterwards the mps got up
and gave him a standing ovation which
was somewhat bizarre given how critical
he had had been of them and then they
just moved on to business as usual
and congratulated a couple of mps for
their on their birthdays that day
and just went on to other matters and
didn't really have anything like a a a
real discussion about what they just
heard from
zielinski and some of the people in the
room in the opposition said
this was sort of the the most
embarrassing day for the bundestag in in
living memory
you know matthew before we run out of
time you know i read your article and i
kept thinking this is exactly what we
have reported
time and time again for the past five
years or so especially over nordstrom 2
and yet
many times it has felt like that there
was no resonance or not even an echo in
the german media
why do you think that is
well i think there's been a tendency in
germany for for decades really in their
relationships with the rest of the world
and in particular with the relationship
with russia to wrap everything in this
sort of moral packaging and say that you
know germany has this historic debt
towards russia and this is why we need
to pursue dialogue as they call it with
russia no matter what happens in reality
something else is going on here this was
a purely mercantilistic policy
that benefited the german economy that
benefited big german industry and uh you
know trying to sell it off as this very
moralistic position i think has put
germany now
in a extremely tough spot because they
would like to just sort of say well
we're going to kind of move on from this
we were wrong
um
you know
as they say in in german they're just
going to wipe the slate clean and and
forget that this happened and i don't
think that uh their allies in europe or
across the atlantic are going to be
willing to let them do that yeah they're
going to need a really big schwarm
that's for sure matthew karnichnik chief
europe correspondent for politico here
in berlin matthew we appreciate your
time tonight thank you
thank you
lombrecht stressed that in light of
russia's aggression germany and its
allies stand closer together than ever
before
putin did not manage to divide nato or
the eu
we stand together and we are reliable
partners
our allies on nato's eastern flank in
particular can rely on this without
question
we support ukraine with arms deliveries
in their incredible fight against a
brutal aggressor
and we in germany will invest in our
security
and nato security
height
will receive an additional 100 billion
euros for this
this is an important contribution and it
was good to hear that it is greatly
appreciated here in washington in
washington
and for more now i want to bring in
thomas silverhorn he's a member of the
german parliament for the conservative
csu party he's also the go-to person for
transatlantic relations mr silberhorn we
appreciate you taking the time to talk
with us
tonight before the invasion
many in washington
had doubts about germany being a
reliable partner when it comes to russia
what do you say to them now five weeks
into this war
germany has always been a reliable
partner in our nato alliance
new is the message that also the new
government completely sticks to the two
percent goal of nato this has not been
the case before it has not been
explicitly laid down in the coalition
treaty on the contrary the green party
explicitly denied to support the two
percent goal this indeed has changed and
this is a very good message for the
german army and for the nato
mr silverhorn there are critics who say
that germany has been on the wrong side
of history for decades with its russia
policy and that it took a war
to make
german politicians see the light
what do you say
the lesson we all have to learn in
particular in europe and in germany is
there is no appeasement that can be
successful
we have to
clearly distinct
between liberal democracies in the west
and autocratic systems like russia and
china there is a systemic gap that
cannot be overruled by which treaty ever
yes we need coordination and cooperation
where this is possible with russia or
with china but there is and there will
always be confrontation in the
substantial issue of the systemic
rivalry between democracies and
autocratic age yeah you mentioned
appeasement
many in washington say it was a
catastrophic mistake
for germany to allow the nordstream 2
pipeline to be constructed you know
former chancellor angela merkel she
refused to say no to the pipeline
was it a mistake that you're now having
to correct
well it has now been corrected and yes
indeed germany is to a large extent
dependent from gas and oil supply from
russia
similar volumes are delivered to the
united states as you know so there is a
variety of arguments on the table but
now things have been clarified after
this brutal attack of russia against
ukraine we have to be aware of the
substantial
preconditions of our bilateral
relations and yes we have to stand at
the right side and this is at the side
of western democracies this is clearer
than ever
i know that there are a lot of people in
washington particularly at the pentagon
who are glad to hear that germany is
increasing its defense spending at the
same time
the head of nato's supreme command for
europe told u.s senators this week that
he expects there to be a permanent
increase in the
number of u.s troops needed to defend
europe against russia
what role is germany going to play here
is germany going to be able to punch
at its weight or even above militarily
in the future
an additional 100 billion euros is a
huge step forward for the german army
for this current legislative period but
it should not lead to the
misunderstanding that you get
a combat ready army by 100 billion euros
only this is again a huge step for the
next few years but much much more is
needed for the current period of nato
and eu planning until 2031.
so yes it's a good message but
government will never be done it's a
permanent task we have to fulfill and
that's why the nato goal of two percent
of our gdp for defense is so crucial and
is much more important than this volume
of 100 billion additional billion for
the next two years
mr thomas silverhorn we appreciate you
taking the time to talk with us tonight
valuable insight into transatlantic
relations at the moment thank you
thank you